un plan de Exterminio contra el partido
de izquierda Unión patriótica de
Colombia así lo calificó la Corte
Interamericana de Derechos Humanos el
día que condenó al Estado colombiano por
violaciones de los propios derechos
humanos contra unos 6000 integrantes y
militantes durante más de dos décadas la
corta dio responsabilidad directa al
estado en crímenes de todo tipo como
desapariciones masacres ejecuciones
extrajudiciales entre otras actos que la
institución judicial ha catalogado de
crímenes de lesa humanidad el fallo
incluye que antes de dos años el estado
inicie investigaciones para esclarecer
la verdad determinar la
responsabilidades penales ubicar el
paradero de las víctimas desaparecidas
realizar un acto Público de
reconocimiento de responsabilidad
nacional Establecer un día de memoria y
diversas actividades de difusión la
unión patriótica nació en 1985 como
resultado de un proceso de paz entre la
guerrilla de las FARC y el gobierno
colombiano pero su rápido ascenso en
política nacional provocó una entre
grupos paramilitares con políticos
militares y empresarios entre las
víctimas de la unión patriótica hubo dos
candidatos a la presidencia Jaime pardo
Leal y Bernardo Jaramillo ossa fue uno
de los distintos grupos de izquierda
contra los que el estado aplicó la
doctrina del enemigo interno provocando
que hasta este 2022 nunca haya habido un
gobierno de izquierda en Colombia
Gustavo Petro se convirtió en el primer
presidente progresista su ejecutivo ha
asegurado que estudiará y acatará la
condena